[Music]
so I'm here with me my Delgado
IFBB professional bodybuilder also
happens to be vegan I've been lacking
protein for quite a while and things are
looking good I don't think I need to
feel great if somebody's looking to dial
up their nutrition dial up their fitness
what are a couple like quick and easy
things that can make a big difference in
somebody's life all right so the first
thing I could probably recommend that
people don't have a good grip on or
grasp is how much they eat I suggest if
you're out there just track your
calories like you normally eat for a
couple days and see what your averages
are and it's a really clear indication
of why you might be gaining weight or
losing weight so most people don't know
how much they should be eating and they
just grab things as they go not knowing
that the foods add up to much more than
what you think you're consuming so best
way to do that would be to use some kind
of calorie tracker My Fitness Pal is
what I use you might find now that
you're eating 2,000 more calories and
you expect and that's probably why you
might have a little bit of a love-handle
so figure out how much you're eating
figure out how much you're supposed to
be eating and then try to reduce that to
that point yeah and on the fitness level
we talked about earlier on the podcast
but I think it's worth mentioning now
consistency is everything yeah
and the fact that you cannot train your
way out of a poor dog yeah you can't out
train a bad diet no matter how hard you
try the diets always gonna take over in
regards to how quickly or how slowly you
see your results so first things first
before you even step foot in the gym get
your nutrition dialed in like I just
mentioned figure out how much you should
be eating figure out what your goal is
how quickly you want to reach your goal
and then determine how much you should
be eating and the best way to do that
would obviously be to eat more Whole
Foods eat more plant-based reduce the
amount of animal proteins that you're
consuming increase the amount of whole
food high protein high carb sources into
your diet and just naturally you can
consume more but it's not always added
with extra calories and I should
unhealthy things like cholesterol so
that's gonna be a big determinant and
how quickly your gains and then show up
every single day man that's the unsexy
part but that's the thing it's gonna I
think for a lot of people just going to
the gym is intimidating they think that
you know they're gonna go into the gym
and they're gonna instantly get judged
by all these other more experienced gym
goers but especially ladies females
always come to me with this problem but
I think what people don't realize is
that most people that go to the gym are
there to look at themselves they're not
there they're not there to look at
anybody else but themselves so just go
to the gym be consistent with it
understand that everybody's in their own
chapter in life in their own fitness
journey the best thing to do is like
rich just said it's just be consistent
with it go every day check the box have
a plan when you walk into the gym and
get your diet in check and eventually
you'll start to see the results that you
dreamed for yeah it is intimidating if
you're new to walk into a gym and see a
bunch of fifth people in the same way
it's intimidating to go to like a bike
shop and look at fancy bikes when you've
never ridden a bike before and you don't
really know the vernacular and you feel
like vulnerable and I think overcoming
that like initial barrier and just
showing up and
and realizing like you said everyone's
thinking about themselves not worry
about what you're doing and and just
having the the courage to show up in
light of that sense of insecurity or
vulnerability I think it's a huge first
step and then it becomes easier and yeah
build momentum and then suddenly you
have a totally different perspective on
this thing they usually scary yeah it
can be overwhelming like you said but
it's just about showing up showing up
the hardest part right yeah of course so
we did a great podcast it's coming soon
I'll let you guys know but thanks for
watching and let me know if you want to
see more of this guy
[Music]
you